This is a video shot not too long ago. When it starts, you can see the gear shift in a car. The camera's shaky. It's a car full of young undocumented immigrants. They park.
这是一段不久前拍摄的视频。刚开始时，可以看到汽车的换挡杆。摄像机在晃动。车里坐满了年轻的无证移民。他们停下了车。
Last words? Last words?
临终遗言？临终遗言？
Take this, ICE.
接招吧，移民海关执法局（ICE）。
The audio isn't so good. One of them said, last words? The other says, take this, ICE. ICE, he means the Immigration and Customs Enforcement Agency, which enforces federal immigration law. The guy who's filming, a 24-year-old named Jonathan Perez puts the camera-- or maybe he's filming with a cellphone-- so that it's peeking out of his coat pocket. You can see the zipper in the frame.
音频不太清晰。其中一个人说，临终遗言？另一个人说，接招吧，ICE。ICE指的是美国移民及海关执法局，负责执行联邦移民法。拍摄的那个人，是一个名叫乔纳森·佩雷斯（Jonathan Perez）的24岁年轻人，他把摄像机——或者他可能是在用手机拍摄——放在大衣口袋里，露在外面。你可以看到画面里的拉链。
He gets out of the car, walks up a sidewalk to a building's front door. And you can catch a glimpse of a doormat that says, US Border Patrol. And you realize, oh, he's going inside.
他下车后，沿着人行道走向一栋建筑的前门。你可以瞥见一块写着“美国边境巡逻队”（US Border Patrol）的门垫。然后你意识到，哦，他要进去了。
Can I help you?
需要帮忙吗？
What is this?
这是什么地方？
Border Patrol.
边境巡逻队。
Oh, [BLEEP].
噢，[消音]。
Did you get that? When he says, what is this, she says, Border Patrol.
听到了吗？当他问这是什么地方时，她说，边境巡逻队。
Yeah, we're lost.
是的，我们迷路了。
He says he's looking for Mobile, Alabama, which he calls Mo-bi-al.
他说他在找阿拉巴马州的莫比尔（Mobile），他把它读作Mo-bi-al。
OK, hang on one second.
好的，请稍等一下。
Nothing happens for about a quarter minute, then two Border Patrol agents enter.
过了大约四分之一分钟什么都没发生，然后两名边境巡逻人员走了进来。
Hey, what's going on, hoss?
嘿，出什么事了，伙计？
Hm?
嗯？
How you doing?
你好吗？
I'm doing good.
我很好。
Can we help you with something?
有什么可以帮你的吗？
What are you all doing here?
你们在这儿干什么？
What are we doing here?
我们在这儿干什么？
Mmhm.
嗯哼。
Doing a job. Why?
工作。怎么了？
What's your job?
你们的工作是什么？
To enforce immigration laws.
执行移民法。
Can we help you--
有什么可以帮我们——
So you all are deporting people?
所以你们是在驱逐移民？
We don't deport people. Judges do that. What's it's to you?
我们不负责驱逐。那是法官的事。这和你有什么关系？
I'm undocumented, too.
我也是无证移民。
You're what?
你说什么？
I'm illegal, too.
我也是非法移民。
Oh, you're illegal?
哦，你是非法移民？
So you think I should get deported?
那你觉得我应该被驱逐吗？
I don't know. Why don't you show us some ID? See what you've got for ID.
我不知道。你为什么不给我们看看身份证件？看看你有什么身份证件。
Soon, the camera clicks off, and the guy gets arrested. OK, why in the world would a young illegal immigrant do this, right, walk into a Border Patrol station, get himself arrested?
很快，摄像机关闭了，那个人被捕了。好吧，一个年轻的非法移民为什么要这样做，对吧，走进边境巡逻站，让自己被捕？
Well, that is what our program is about today, about people doing the one thing that they are not supposed to do. What makes that happen? We have three stories in today's show. One of the stories is this one. One is about a teenager who listens to her parents, gets good grades, follows all the rules, until she disobeys the one ironclad rule she was never supposed to disobey. And one story involves a moose that engages in some very un-moose-like behavior, I think you'll agree.
嗯，这就是我们今天节目的主题，关于人们去做那件他们本不该做的事情。是什么导致了这种情况？我们今天的节目有三个故事。其中一个故事就是刚才这个。另一个是关于一个听父母话、成绩优异、遵守所有规则的少女，直到她违背了那条她永远不该违背的铁律。还有一个故事涉及一只行为非常不像麋鹿的麋鹿，我想你会同意这一点的。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass, and let's just get to it. Let's get to the first act.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass），我们直接开始吧。让我们进入第一幕。
Act One, Breaking the Ice. So OK, why does a kid like Jonathan Perez get himself arrested on purpose by Border Patrol? OK, well, here is where he's coming from.
第一幕，打破僵局。好吧，为什么像乔纳森·佩雷斯这样的孩子会故意让自己被边境巡逻队逮捕？好了，这就是他的初衷。
And Bob, do we have any idea how old some of the protesters are?
鲍勃，我们知道这些抗议者中有些人的年龄吗？
There they go. All right.
他们去了。好吧。
OK, these activists are young. They're in their early 20s, and they are undocumented. You've seen them in the news over the years, probably.
好的，这些活动家都很年轻。他们才20出头，而且都是无证移民。你可能多年来在新闻中见过他们。
And a lot of them have this very sympathetic story. They were brought here when they were little. They grew up here in the United States. Some of them only found out they were illegal when they got old enough to apply to college and found out they could not go to college in this country.
他们中的许多人都有着非常令人同情的背景。他们小时候被带到这里。他们在美利坚合众国长大。有些人直到到了上大学的年龄，发现自己在这个国家无法上大学时，才知道自己是非法移民。
These are the kids that the Dream Act was designed to put on a path to citizenship. And fighting to get the Dream Act passed is what got many of them into politics. And they have not been shy about using confrontational tactics to get their point across. They block traffic. They get arrested. They lobby Congress wearing graduation gowns. And by 2009, they had stumbled onto this new tactic.
这些孩子就是《梦想法案》（Dream Act）旨在帮助他们获得公民身份的那类人。为争取《梦想法案》通过而进行的斗争，使他们中的许多人投身政治。他们毫不避讳使用对抗性的策略来表达自己的观点。他们阻断交通。他们被捕。他们穿着毕业袍在国会游说。到了2009年，他们偶然发现了一种新策略。
Hello, I'm Walter Lara. As you know, I'm being deported this 4th of July weekend.
大家好，我是沃尔特·拉拉（Walter Lara）。如你们所知，这个7月4日的周末我将被驱逐出境。
When kids like Walter Lara right here, who would have been helped by the Dream Act, got pulled into deportation hearings, they made internet videos, they went to the press, they organized petition drives, they got senators to write letters on their behalf. And amazingly, this worked. Walter was allowed to stay. And you can just imagine how this caught on. One of the groups helping immigrants do this was the National Immigration Youth Alliance, NIYA. Mohammad Abdollahi-- everybody calls him Mo-- is one of its leaders.
当像沃尔特·拉拉这样本应从《梦想法案》中受益的孩子被卷入驱逐听证会时，他们制作了网络视频，联系媒体，组织请愿活动，让参议员为他们写信。令人惊讶的是，这奏效了。沃尔特获准留下。你可以想象这方法是如何流行开来的。帮助移民做这件事的组织之一是全国移民青年联盟（NIYA）。穆罕默德·阿卜杜拉希（Mohammad Abdollahi）——大家都叫他Mo——是该组织的领导人之一。
From there, every time we would do a case, another person would-- it would literally work like dominoes. We would do one case, and then we had somebody else contact us. And then we'd do that case, and then we'd have somebody else contact us. So it was just a complete domino effect, every month pretty much doing a different case of somebody that would contact us from the previous one.
从那时起，我们每处理一个案例，另一个人就会……这就像多米诺骨牌一样。我们处理一个案例，就会有其他人联系我们。然后我们处理那个案例，又会有其他人联系我们。所以这简直就是彻底的多米诺骨牌效应，每个月几乎都在处理由上一个案例联系我们的不同的人的案件。
OK, so it's going great for two years. And then the activists thought, OK, let's scale this up, not just do one person at a time. Let's go for a big group all at once. And just think about it. If you want to help a big group of people who are about to get deported, where could you find them? Well, the obvious place, an immigration detention center.
好了，一切进展顺利了两年。然后活动家们想，好吧，让我们把规模扩大，不要一次只做一个人的案件。让我们一次针对一大群人。想想看。如果你想帮助一大群即将被驱逐出境的人，你在哪里能找到他们？嗯，显而易见的地方，移民拘留中心。
Mo thought all they needed to do is get inside a detention center that was full of people who are about to get deported. And he thought, that should be no problem, right? Because he and his activist friends were also illegal immigrants. They could get themselves detained. And you might think that his friends would say, no way. That's nuts.
Mo认为他们只需要进入一个满是即将被驱逐出境的人的拘留中心即可。他觉得这应该没问题，对吧？因为他和他的活动家朋友们也都是非法移民。他们可以让自己被拘留。你可能会认为他的朋友们会说，不行，那太疯狂了。
No, when I called people, everyone was super down. Yeah, I just quit my job. Why not? It was pretty much a response of, like, how long? And let's do it. Why not?
不，当我打电话给他们时，每个人都非常支持。是的，我刚辞了工作。为什么不呢？他们的反应几乎是，“要待多久？让我们开始吧。为什么不呢？”
Hence, the video from Alabama of Jonathan Perez getting himself arrested. That was their first attempt at a radical, in your face, bank heist version of this. And by the time the activists tried that, they also had a new weapon at their side.
因此，就有了来自阿拉巴马州的乔纳森·佩雷斯让自己被逮捕的视频。那是他们第一次尝试进行激进的、对抗性的、类似银行抢劫版本的行动。当活动家们尝试这样做时，他们身边还有一件新武器。
There was a set of government documents that unless you are involved in this issue, you've probably never heard of. These documents are known as the Morton Memos, named after John Morton, President Obama's current head of the Immigration and Customs Enforcement agency, ICE. He's actually leaving the job next month.
有一套政府文件，除非你关注这个问题，否则你可能从未听说过。这些文件被称为“莫顿备忘录”（Morton Memos），以奥巴马总统现任移民及海关执法局（ICE）局长约翰·莫顿（John Morton）的名字命名。他实际上下个月就要离职了。
And the memos say, basically, that since the United States does not have the money and resources to deport all 11 million illegal immigrants that are in this country, we have to prioritize. So it says, let's focus on the people that we most want to get rid of. And those are, of course, criminals.
备忘录基本上说，由于美国没有足够的资金和资源驱逐国内所有的1100万非法移民，我们必须设定优先事项。所以它说，让我们专注于我们最想驱逐的人。当然，这些人就是罪犯。
And as for all the other people who are undocumented but don't break other laws-- let's say you have a job, you go to church, you raise your kids, you work hard, you pay your taxes. You are low priority. We're not coming after you, the administration is saying. Here's the president at a town meeting on Univision.
至于所有其他无证但没有触犯其他法律的人——假设你有工作、去教堂、抚养孩子、努力工作、纳税。你属于低优先级。政府说，我们不会去抓你们。这是总统在Univision电视台的市政厅会议上所说的。
And so our deportation of criminals are up about 70%. Our deportation of non-criminals are down. And that's because we want to focus our resources on those folks who are destructive to the community. And for a young person like that young woman that we just spoke to who's going to school, doing all the right things, we want them to succeed.
因此，我们对罪犯的驱逐率上升了约70%。我们对非罪犯的驱逐率有所下降。这是因为我们希望将资源集中在那些对社区具有破坏性的人身上。而对于像我们刚才提到的那位正在上学、做着正确事情的年轻人，我们希望他们成功。
But there's a catch to all this, the way that the Morton Memos work. And that is, these memos are just guidelines. They're just recommendations to the ICE field offices. They are not legally binding.
但所有这些都有个陷阱，就是莫顿备忘录的运作方式。那就是，这些备忘录仅仅是指导方针。它们只是给ICE地方办公室的建议。它们没有法律约束力。
If an ICE office stumbles on a low priority immigrant and feels like it has the resources to detain or deport that immigrant, it can do that. And so lots of people are getting detained who the Morton Memos say should not be. And just in case you don't know this, overall, President Obama has been deporting people at a quicker rate than any previous president.
如果一个ICE办公室偶然发现了低优先级的移民，并觉得有资源拘留或驱逐该移民，它就可以这样做。所以很多人被拘留了，而按照莫顿备忘录的说法，他们本不该被拘留。顺便提一下，总体而言，奥巴马总统驱逐移民的速度比之前的任何一位总统都要快。
OK, which brings us back to our activists. Remember, they wanted to get into a detention center. They wanted to help release the kinds of people who would be covered under the Morton Memos, these low priority detainees. And that video that you heard of Jonathan Perez getting himself arrested was the very first time they tried to get themselves locked up. It was a test of whether they could get themselves put into a detention center, gather evidence, and then later get themselves released. And this worked.
好了，这把我们带回了我们的活动家身上。记住，他们想进入拘留中心。他们想帮助释放那些会被莫顿备忘录涵盖的低优先级被拘留者。你听到的那个乔纳森·佩雷斯让自己被逮捕的视频，是他们第一次尝试让自己被关进去。这是对他们能否让自己被送进拘留中心、收集证据、然后被释放的一次测试。而且成功了。
So a half year after that, July 2012, the activists decided to try again and take things further. This time, they were really going to try to get lots of people set free. Reporter Michael May picks up the story from this point and explains what happened next.
半年后，即2012年7月，活动家们决定再试一次，并进一步深入。这一次，他们真的要设法让很多人获释。记者迈克尔·梅（Michael May）从这里开始讲述故事，并解释了接下来发生的事情。
Their next target was a detention center in Florida called the Broward Transitional Center. Broward only holds non-violent illegal immigrants, the very people the Morton Memos were designed to steer away from deportation proceedings. Since Broward is segregated by gender, the plan was for a man and a woman to go in.
他们的下一个目标是佛罗里达州的一个拘留中心，名叫布劳沃德过渡中心（Broward Transitional Center）。布劳沃德只关押非暴力的非法移民，正是那些莫顿备忘录旨在将他们排除在驱逐程序之外的人。由于布劳沃德是按性别分区的，他们的计划是一男一女进去。
The man was Marco Saavedra. He's 23. His parents farmed a tiny patch of land in Mexico and brought him to the US when he was a toddler. Through some lucky breaks, Marco went to a fancy boarding school and then to a private college that accepted illegal immigrants.
那个人是马可·萨维德拉（Marco Saavedra）。他今年23岁。他的父母在墨西哥经营一小块土地，在他还是个蹒跚学步的孩子时就把他带到了美国。经过一些幸运的机会，马可上了一所高级寄宿学校，然后上了一所接收非法移民的私立大学。
He wears wire-rimmed glasses. He's earnest and thoughtful, uses words like hegemony in regular conversation. And here he was trying to get locked up.
他戴着金属框眼镜。他真诚而深思熟虑，在日常谈话中会使用“霸权”之类的词。而此时他正试图让自己被关进去。
I got really nervous. And I was-- I guess it's not the worst thing to get arrested.
我非常紧张。而且我当时是……我想被逮捕也不是最糟糕的事情。
So on a bright, sunny Florida morning last July, Marco dresses up like a day laborer and drives with some other activists to a commercial port with freighters and cruise ships and a lot of security. They had heard of people being detained there before.
所以在去年7月一个阳光明媚的佛罗里达早晨，马可打扮成日薪工人的样子，和一些其他活动家开车前往一个有货轮、游轮和大量安保的商业港口。他们听说过以前有人在那里被拘留。
I mean, there's, like, two booths. And there's always a guard that needs to check everyone that goes in and out.
我的意思是，那里有两个岗亭。而且总有一个警卫需要检查进出的每个人。
The other activists drop him off and drive to a nearby CVS drugstore and park. Marco walks up to the security booth.
其他活动家把他放下，开车到附近的一家CVS药店停车。马可走向保安亭。
I'm saying like,
我当时在说，
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
A job, a job. I just keep on saying that.
一份工作，一份工作。我一直重复这句话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
I have no money, or something like that. And he just said, go home. I can't do anything for you. And I'm not going to call the police.
我没钱，或者诸如此类的话。他只是说，回家去吧。我不能为你做什么。而且我不会报警。
So I'm like-- I walk, like, 100 feet away and then I call the folks that are in the CVS parking lot saying, I was shut down. What do I do? And they just said, go back. So three minutes later, I'm right back at the guard in a Kafka-esque situation, like, kind of begging them to take me in. Like, I need a job. I have no money. I'm hungry.
所以我当时就……我走了大约100英尺远，然后给那些在CVS停车场的人打电话说，我被拒绝了。我该怎么办？他们只说，回去。所以三分钟后，我又回到了那个警卫面前，处在一种卡夫卡式的境地，简直像是在乞求他们把我带进去。就像是，我需要一份工作。我没钱。我很饿。
But no matter what Marco said, the guard just wasn't in the mood to call the cops on him. Again, Marco walks away. Again, he calls his friends. Again they tell him to keep trying. So he goes back. Gets sent away again. At this point, he's just baffled by how hard this is.
但无论马可说什么，警卫就是没心情报警。马可又走了。他又给朋友打电话。他们又告诉他继续尝试。所以他又回去了。又被赶走了。到了这个时候，他对这件事如此困难感到困惑。
Finally, after three or four rounds of this, Marco just refuses to go away. And then he gets what he wants. The guard calls over a police officer.
最终，经过三四轮这样的过程，马可就是拒绝离开。然后他如愿以偿了。警卫叫来了一名警官。
He was, like, a big-- I mean, he's a big white guy. He's, like, in his 40s. But he's, like, friendly, right? So he's like, how are you? Like [SPANISH]. He tries to speak his minimal Spanish greeting.
他像是一个大块头……我的意思是，他是一个身材高大的白人。大约40多岁。但他很友好，对吧？所以他说，你好吗？像是（西班牙语）。他试图用他那有限的西班牙语问候。
And then again, I gave the cop the same spiel of like, I'm looking for a job. Let me in. The guard hasn't let me in. I really need a job because I'm hungry. I don't have any money. I show him my wallet. I show him that I just have a Mexican ID card and, like, $2.
然后我又给了那个警察同样的辞令，就像是，我在找工作。让我进去。警卫没让我进去。我真的很需要一份工作，因为我很饿。我没钱。我给他看我的钱包。我给他看我只有一张墨西哥身份证和大约2美元。
Marco was like, now we're cooking. But the cop also refuses to take the bait. Even though Marco is really pulling out all the stops, talking about how he crossed the desert with a bunch of people. He even says it flat out.
马可当时想，我们要成功了。但警察也拒绝上钩。尽管马可真的竭尽全力，谈论他是如何和一群人穿越沙漠的。他甚至直截了当地说了。
And I do. I do say, like, I don't have papers.
我也确实说了，我没有证件。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
And he continuously says, don't tell me you're illegal. Don't tell me you're illegal. He's, like, begging me not to tell him that I'm illegal. At one point the cop-- I mean, I think he almost wants to throw up his hands and say, just go home. We'll pretend this never happened.
他不断地说，不要告诉我你是非法移民。不要告诉我你是非法移民。他就像是在求我不要告诉他我是非法移民。有一次那个警察……我想他几乎想一摊手说，回家吧。我们就当这事从未发生过。
So he opens up his wallet. And it looks like just singles. And so to shoo me away, he offers me $5 to get on the bus. And I just refuse just because it's so weird.
所以他打开了他的钱包。看起来只有几张零钞。为了把我打发走，他给了我5美元让我去坐公交车。我拒绝了，因为这太奇怪了。
All these young activists, they'd heard stories of people being detained for hardly any reason. The guy who dropped his kid off at school and a cop sees him and detains him. Or the one pulled over for making a wide right turn. But Marco can't seem to get detained no matter what he does.
所有这些年轻的活动家都听说过人们因各种几乎不成理由的原因而被拘留的故事。比如一个人送孩子上学，警察看见他并拘留了他。或者因为转弯太宽而被拦下。但马可无论怎么做似乎都无法被拘留。
That is really strange. And it's so arbitrary.
那真的很奇怪。而且太随意了。
Eventually, he gives up. They leave the port and go somewhere that seems like it has to be a sure bet, the immigration office at the Fort Lauderdale airport.
最后，他放弃了。他们离开了港口，去了一个看起来应该是稳操胜券的地方——劳德代尔堡机场的移民办公室。
We knock on the door, and the agent just shuts the door on my face. And he's just like, go away. Don't bother me.
我们敲门，代理人直接把门关在我脸上。他只是说，走开。别烦我。
The next morning, they decide to keep it simple. They drop Marco off right in front of a Border Patrol station.
第二天早上，他们决定保持简单。他们把马可直接放在一个边境巡逻站前。
I just go to the front door and just ring the bell. Someone responds, and I say,
我直接走到前门按了门铃。有人回应，我说，
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
I'm looking for my cousin. And the lady is just like, one moment, sir. An agent will come out to see you. And so this big agent-- he's pretty tall, maybe six foot two, glasses. His hair is thinning because he's probably in his 40s.
我在找我的堂兄。那个女士说，稍等一下，先生。会有代理人出来见你。然后那个大个子代理人走出来——他很高，大约六英尺二，戴着眼镜。头发有些稀疏，因为他可能40多岁了。
He comes out with a pad, and he's wearing his Border Patrol uniform, which is just all green khakis. And I just say, like, I'm looking for my cousin. We think that he was stopped near Broadway Avenue. He doesn't have papers, so we went to the police, but we were thinking that maybe Border Patrol stopped him. And then I said something like, because we all came here together.
他拿着写字板出来，穿着边境巡逻队的制服，就是那种全绿色的卡其装。我只是说，我在找我的堂兄。我们认为他是在百老汇大道附近被拦下的。他没有证件，所以我们找了警察，但我们想也许是边境巡逻队拦下了他。然后我说了类似的话，因为我们是一起来到这里的。
(ON RECORDING) We all came together.
（录音中）我们是一起来的。
Marco used his cell phone to record the conversation. It's fuzzy and hard to hear, but Marco goes around and around with the guy for a while. Finally, the agent asks him directly, so you're illegal too? Marco says, yes. The officer says, you know I have to arrest you.
马可使用他的手机录下了这段谈话。录音很模糊，很难听清，但马可和那个人周旋了一会儿。最后，代理人直接问他，所以你也是非法移民？马可说是。警察说，你知道我必须逮捕你。
You know I have to arrest you.
你知道我必须逮捕你。
Oh.
哦。
Yeah. Put your hands behind your back. You presented yourself to a-- I'm a law officer. I have to arrest you.
是的。把手放到背后。你出现在一个……我是法律官员。我必须逮捕你。
You can hear how surprised the agent is, like someone who's fishing and has a fish jump into their boat.
你可以听出那个代理人有多惊讶，就像一个钓鱼的人发现有一条鱼跳进了他的船里。
I'm still holding the phone in my hand, so you can hear the handcuffs clicking as I turn the phone off.
我手里还拿着手机，所以你可以听到我关掉手机时手铐咔哒的声音。
[HANDCUFFS CLICKING]
（手铐声）
What kind of risk was Marco taking getting locked up? Well, by this point, President Obama had announced a sort of watered down version of the Dream Act, and Marco met its requirements. On the other hand, he had a criminal record from protests he'd been at-- disorderly conduct.
马可因被关进去承担了什么样的风险？嗯，到这个时候，奥巴马总统已经宣布了一个《梦想法案》的缩水版本，而马可满足了其要求。另一方面，他因为参与抗议活动留下了犯罪记录——行为不检。
And as he was being processed by an agent who thought Marco didn't speak any English, the agent took a look at his criminal record and said, this guy will be a bag and ready case. They filed paperwork to begin deportation proceedings. And those are still going ahead today.
当他被一个认为马可不会说英语的代理人处理时，代理人看了一眼他的犯罪记录说，这家伙是个注定要被驱逐的案例。他们提交了文件开始驱逐程序。而这些程序直到今天仍在进行。
The young woman who was going to get herself detained is an honors student over-achiever type named Viridiana Martinez. She goes by Viri. She had to try twice before a cop reluctantly detained her and sent her to Broward.
那个即将让自己被拘留的年轻女性是一名成绩优异的尖子生，名叫维里迪安娜·马丁内斯（Viridiana Martinez）。她自称Viri。她尝试了两次，警察才勉强拘留了她，并把她送到了布劳沃德。
My brother was like, whoa, dude, you're in the pen? Shut up. When are you getting out?
我哥哥说，哇，伙计，你在监狱里？闭嘴。你什么时候出来？
She called her family and tried to explain why she took the risk. Everybody reacted differently.
她打电话给家人，试图解释她为什么要冒险。每个人的反应都不一样。
I told my mom. I told her on the phone. And she was like why are you doing that? And I was like, Mom, because it could be you.
我告诉了我妈妈。我在电话里告诉了她。她说你为什么要这样做？我说，妈，因为这可能会发生在你身上。
And it's not right that people go through this, you know? And you say that you have faith, and you go to church and you believe in God. Well, then, Mom, it's time to put that faith to practice. I'm going to be fine.
人们经历这些是不对的，你知道吗？你说你有信仰，你去教堂，你相信上帝。嗯，那么，妈，是时候把这种信仰付诸实践了。我会没事的。
And my dad, ever since-- this was like, I had already been arrested before. And my dad always says, like, are you ready to go back to Mexico? Well, if you're ready to go to Mexico, then go ahead. I'm like, OK, Dad. Thanks.
我爸爸，从那以后……因为我已经因为抗议被捕过一次。我爸爸总是说，你准备好回墨西哥了吗？好吧，如果你准备好去墨西哥了，那就去吧。我说，好的，爸。谢谢。
The night that Marco got arrested, a man inside Broward, a detainee named Claudio Rojas, got a phone call.
马可被捕的那天晚上，布劳沃德里面的一名被拘留者克劳迪奥·罗哈斯（Claudio Rojas）接到了一通电话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
My son had called me that night.
我儿子那天晚上给我打了电话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
He told me he had a surprise for me.
他告诉我他有一个惊喜要给我。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
And that I would find out.
我会发现的。
At this point, Claudio had been in Broward for several months. And his lawyer had been arguing that he was a Morton Memo case. He was a hardworking family man with nice kids who paid his taxes and was devoutly Christian. He'd been in the US for almost 12 years. His lawyer argued he should not be locked up, much less deported.
此时，克劳迪奥已经在布劳沃德待了几个月。他的律师一直在辩称他是一个莫顿备忘录案例。他是一个辛勤工作的顾家男人，有可爱的孩子，纳税且虔诚信仰基督教。他在美国待了近12年。他的律师认为他不应该被关押，更不应该被驱逐。
Claudo is a people person, kind of a natural organizer. And talking to other prisoners, he realized there were lots of people like him who would be covered by the Morton Memos. So completely on his own, he started collecting names and passing them to his son on the outside. And his son contacted the activists at NIYA. That's one of the reasons NIYA decided to send Marco and Viri into Broward. But Claudio was in the dark about all that except for the phone call telling him a surprise was on the way. The next morning--
克劳迪奥是一个善于交际的人，算是一个天生的组织者。在和其他囚犯交谈时，他意识到里面有很多像他一样符合莫顿备忘录条件的人。于是，他完全靠自己开始收集名字，并传递给外面的儿子。他的儿子联系了NIYA的活动家。这就是NIYA决定派马可和Viri进入布劳沃德的原因之一。但克劳迪奥对这一切一无所知，除了那个告诉他有惊喜在路上的电话。第二天早上——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
I was in my room.
我在房间里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
And Marco opens the door.
马可打开了门。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
And he asks for Claudio Rojas.
他询问克劳迪奥·罗哈斯。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
He tells me, I know your son.
他告诉我，我认识你儿子。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
And then he explains how they met, and that's when I realized this was the surprise my son was talking about.
然后他解释了他们是如何认识的，这时我意识到这就是我儿子所说的惊喜。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
I say, what are you doing here, Marco?
我说，马可，你在这里做什么？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
He says, I came to help you.
他说，我来帮你。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
You came to help me. Yeah.
你来帮我。是的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Well, let's get to work. And that's when we began to work. We didn't waste a second.
好吧，让我们开始工作吧。就在那时我们开始了工作。我们没浪费一秒钟。
Just like that, the plan was under way. Claudio began introducing Marco to people, showing him around the detention center.
就这样，计划开始了。克劳迪奥开始把马可介绍给其他人，带他参观拘留中心。
Broward is a strange place. It's in the suburbs of Fort Lauderdale, across the street from a Domino's Pizza. Except for the walls around the perimeter, it could be mistaken for a low budget retirement home. It's painted pastel pink. There's a courtyard with palm trees and a volleyball court. But everyone wears orange jumpsuits. Marco says it's low security, but it still feels like a jail.
布劳沃德是一个奇怪的地方。它位于劳德代尔堡的郊区，马路对面就是一家多米诺披萨。除了围墙外，它可能被误认为是一个低成本的养老院。它被漆成淡粉色。有一个种着棕榈树的庭院和一个排球场。但每个人都穿着橙色的连体衣。马可说这是低风险级别，但仍然感觉像监狱。
It's like a nightmarish boarding school would look like. I mean, it feels like if you were confined to a really, really cheap motel room that you couldn't get out of, that's basically what it feels like.
看起来像噩梦般的寄宿学校。我的意思是，感觉就像你被困在一个非常非常便宜的汽车旅馆房间里，出不去，基本上就是这种感觉。
Though the doors aren't locked, there are hours during the day when the detainees are not allowed to leave their rooms. Marco says, kind of the only thing to do is watch TV. As Claudio showed Marco how everything worked, he also told him about what he'd been finding-- that there were all these Morton Memo types at Broward who should be able to get out. And Claudio said that deportation officers openly admitted that those memos, those mean nothing.
虽然门没有锁，但在白天，被拘留者被禁止离开房间。马可说，唯一能做的事就是看电视。当克劳迪奥向马可展示一切运作方式时，也告诉了他自己的发现——布劳沃德里有所有这些符合莫顿备忘录类型的人，他们本应该能够出去。克劳迪奥说，驱逐官员公开承认这些备忘录毫无意义。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
I've heard immigration agents tell people who were fighting for their rights, tell them, President Obama isn't going to tell me how to do my job.
我听过移民代理人告诉那些争取权利的人，告诉他们，奥巴马总统不会教我如何做我的工作。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Because their job is to deport people. The president in his presidency and me here.
因为他们的工作就是驱逐人。总统是他的总统任期，而我是这里的主宰。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
That's how things were done.
事情就是这样处理的。
He heard people say that?
他听到人们这么说？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Of course.
当然。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
It was every day.
每天都是这样。
Marco and Claudio began to move systematically through Broward. They went door to door, interviewing the some 600 guys inside, one room at a time. They interviewed detainees in the courtyard, in the cafeteria, in the game room. Always, their plan was to figure out who qualified to get out under the Morton Memos. They wanted the most sympathetic cases they could find. It was a big job.
马可和克劳迪奥开始系统性地在布劳沃德行动。他们挨家挨户地采访里面的600名左右的人，一次一个房间。他们在庭院里、食堂里、游戏室里采访被拘留者。他们的计划始终是找出谁有资格根据莫顿备忘录获释。他们想要找到最令人同情的案例。这是一个巨大的工作。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
We began speaking individually with the detained, asking them what their situation was.
我们开始单独与被拘留者交谈，询问他们的情况。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
If they had wives, kids, how long they'd been in the country.
他们是否有妻子、孩子，在该国待了多久。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
If they had criminal records.
他们是否有犯罪记录。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Something that could help them.
任何能帮助他们的东西。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
And all of that, we turned over to the people outside, the people with Mohammad.
所有这些，我们都转交给了外面的人，穆罕默德的那群人。
So the role of the outside team was, essentially, we fielded calls all day.
所以外部团队的角色本质上就是整天接听电话。
This is Mo, Mohammad Abdollahi, the guy who came up with the idea to infiltrate Broward. While Marco and Viri were inside, Mo and the others had set up at a house not far away where they were pulling together all the information coming out of Broward.
这就是Mo，穆罕默德·阿卜杜拉希，那个想出渗透布劳沃德主意的人。当马可和Viri在里面时，Mo和其他人在不远处的一所房子里建立了一个指挥中心，汇总来自布劳沃德的所有信息。
We'd get our first call every morning like clockwork. I'd be sleeping-- 7:00 AM-- because Claudio was a gardener, so he's used to waking up really early in the morning. So every morning, 7:00 AM, Marco would call me. And every morning, he'd give me a list of 20 names-- at least 20 names, if not more, of people to contact.
我们每天早上都会准时接到第一个电话。我当时在睡觉——凌晨7点——因为克劳迪奥是个园丁，所以他习惯很早就起床。所以每天早上7点，马可都会给我打电话。每天早上，他都会给我一个名单，至少20个名字，甚至更多，是我们需要联系的人。
The first thing they'd do with these names is to make an attempt to vet the person's story, call friends and family to make sure they were telling the truth. If they thought the person really did have grounds to be let out, they'd launch a public campaign to get them released.
他们处理这些名字的第一件事是尝试核实这个人的故事，给朋友和家人打电话确保他们说的是实话。如果他们认为这个人确实有被释放的理由，他们就会发起一场公开运动来促使他们获释。
They'd put up an online petition that told their story. They'd help families hold press conferences and vigils, help them get media attention. They'd reach out to the detainee's church and get them involved.
他们会发起在线请愿书讲述他们的故事。他们会帮助家属召开新闻发布会和守夜活动，帮助他们获得媒体关注。他们会联系被拘留者的教堂并让他们参与进来。
They'd urge people to call politicians and give them sample scripts asking congressmen and senators to intervene with immigration authorities. Day after day, Marco and Viri and Claudio were now roaming the halls of Broward, slipping people tiny pieces of paper with the phone number of the activists in the house outside. Here's Mo.
他们会敦促人们打电话给政客，提供脚本样本，要求国会议员和参议员干预移民当局。一天又一天，马可、Viri和克劳迪奥现在在布劳沃德的走廊里漫步，偷偷给人们递上写有外面活动家电话号码的小纸条。这是Mo。
Initially, when we got to Florida, everybody would call my phone, because that was the number that Marco and Viridiana had memorized. After the third day or so, it got to the point where literally every 30 seconds, we were getting a phone call from a family member from the facility or somebody in the detention center calling us. And that's when we realized, we can't do this with just one phone.
最初，我们到佛罗里达时，每个人都会拨打我的手机，因为那是马可和维里迪安娜背下来的号码。大约第三天左右，事情发展到基本上每30秒，我们就会接到来自设施内家属或拘留中心某人的电话。那时我们意识到，我们不能只靠一部电话处理这件事。
So the group set up a hotline and enlisted activists in several other states to help field calls from detainees in Broward.
所以该小组设立了一条热线，并招募了其他几个州的活动家来帮助接听布劳沃德被拘留者的电话。
This is Lindora. I talked to you about Hugo. He's in the Broward County Detention Center.
我是琳多拉。我跟你谈过雨果的事。他在布劳沃德县拘留中心。
These are recordings from that line. It's hundreds of calls and messages.
这些是来自那条线路的录音。有成百上千的电话和留言。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
（西班牙语）。
Most of the calls are in Spanish. You can often hear children crying or playing. A few tell whole stories.
大部分电话是西班牙语。你经常能听到孩子在哭或玩耍。少数人讲述了完整的故事。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
This woman named Elefsina, she got the number from her husband who had been in Broward for months. She says, please, truly, from my heart, I need you to help me. I have three children. One who's 16 is disabled.
这个叫埃莱夫西娜（Elefsina）的女人，从她在布劳沃德待了几个月的丈夫那里得到了号码。她说，求求你，真的，从心底里，我需要你们帮我。我有三个孩子。其中一个16岁的孩子是残疾人。
He says he's worthless, that he's a nobody, the he won't be able to help me. He made it clear that he wants to kill himself because he doesn't have his father. At this point, she starts to cry.
他说他毫无价值，他是个没用的人，他无法帮我。他明确表示他想自杀，因为他没有父亲。说到这里，她开始哭泣。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
And then she finishes, please, please, I need you to help me. I need you to help me get my husband out. He is a good father, a hard worker. Please help me.
最后她说，求求你们，求求你们，我需要你们帮我。我需要你们帮我救出我丈夫。他是个好父亲，是个勤劳的人。求求你们帮帮我。
It may seem strange that a bunch of 20-somethings with no legal experience could become the best option for so many detainees so quickly. But most detainees at Broward have no lawyers. Immigration violations don't qualify you for a free public defender.
一群没有任何法律经验的20多岁年轻人能如此迅速地成为这么多被拘留者的最佳选择，这似乎很奇怪。但布劳沃德的大多数被拘留者都没有律师。移民违规不足以让你获得免费的公设辩护人。
I talked to a lawyer who does pro bono work inside. She told me most of the detainees are confused, can't afford a private lawyer, don't know their rights. Sometimes she has to explain to them what the place is and why they're there.
我和一位在里面做公益工作的律师谈过。她告诉我，大多数被拘留者感到困惑，请不起私人律师，不知道自己的权利。有时她不得不向他们解释那里是什么地方，以及他们为什么在那里。
This lawyer, her name is Jessica Shulruff. She works for a group called Americans for Immigrant Justice. She said that most of the people she encounters in Broward shouldn't be there. But last year, when she provided ICE with a list of all the people who would qualify under the Morton Memos--
这位律师名叫杰西卡·舒尔鲁夫（Jessica Shulruff）。她为“美国移民公正组织”（Americans for Immigrant Justice）工作。她说，她在布劳沃德遇到的大多数人本不应该在那里。但去年，当她向ICE提供了一份所有符合莫顿备忘录资格的人的名单时——
To say, these are individuals that we feel would benefit under the Memos that you should take a look at to go ahead and release quickly. And in conversations with ICE officials, they came back to us and said, no, we need you to provide individual documentation for each of these individuals. In all honesty, the purpose of the memo was for ICE to be reviewing these cases on their own. And so that's, I think, what's been problematic.
她说，这些人是我们认为会从备忘录中受益的个体，你们应该看一看并尽快释放他们。而在与ICE官员的交谈中，他们回复我们说，不，我们需要你们为每个人提供个人证明文件。老实说，备忘录的目的是为了让ICE自行审查这些案件。所以我认为这就是问题所在。
The reality is that the implementation of the Morton Memos has been tangled and messy. Lawyers like Shulruff say that ICE should be investigating the detainees, that most detainees, while they're locked up, have no way to gather the documents and witnesses they'd need. Most, as I've said, have no lawyers. ICE, meanwhile, says it's not their job to investigate. It's their job to review all the evidence that detainees show them.
事实是，莫顿备忘录的执行一直混乱不堪。像舒尔鲁夫这样的律师表示，ICE应该调查被拘留者，而大多数被拘留者在被关押期间，无法收集他们所需的证据和证人。如我所说，大多数人没有律师。而ICE则表示，调查不是他们的工作。他们的工作是审查被拘留者向他们出示的所有证据。
Then there's the question of whether ICE should be detaining any low priority cases at all. Immigration lawyers like Shulruff argue that if someone squarely falls within the guidelines of the Memos, the answer is no.
然后，ICE是否应该拘留任何低优先级案例也存在问题。像舒尔鲁夫这样的移民律师认为，如果某人完全符合备忘录的准则，答案是不。
When I talked to the head of ICE in Florida, the guy who's in charge of Broward, he saw it differently. His name is Marc Moore. He says the Memos clearly allow him to detain low priority immigrants. Let's say his agents run across two illegal immigrants. One is high priority, and one is a typical low priority case, stopped on a traffic violation.
当我与佛罗里达州ICE的负责人谈话时，那个负责布劳沃德的人，他有不同的看法。他叫马克·摩尔（Marc Moore）。他说备忘录明确允许他拘留低优先级移民。假设他的代理人遇到了两个非法移民。一个是高优先级的，另一个是典型的低优先级案例，因交通违规被拦下。
So if it's a choice between somebody who has an aggravated felony for manslaughter or a choice between somebody with no driver's license, both are illegally present in the United States and subject to removal. Director Morton is clear that he wants us to focus on the one that presents the greatest threat to public safety, and we would go after the individual with the aggravated felony crime.
因此，如果选择是在一个有严重过失杀人重罪的人和一个没有驾照的人之间，两人都是非法居留美国并面临遣返。莫顿局长明确表示，他希望我们专注于那个对公共安全构成最大威胁的人，我们会追捕那个犯有严重重罪的人。
Now, does that mean we're going to turn a blind eye to everyone else? Not necessarily. Where there's an ability to do both, then sometimes yes, we're able to do both.
现在，这是否意味着我们要对其他人视而不见？不一定。在有能力处理两者的情况下，有时是的，我们有能力处理两者。
Moore is saying that if he's got the manpower and resources to deport them both, that's what he'll do. The low priority detainee will be deported. And he's right. The Morton Memos leave him that discretion.
摩尔的意思是，如果他有人力和资源把他们两个都驱逐出去，那他就会这么做。低优先级被拘留者将被驱逐。而且他是对的。莫顿备忘录留给了他这种裁量权。
So though a memo from December 12th states that only real criminals, not people with traffic offenses, should be detained, one page later, it says, and I quote, "Nothing in this guidance should be construed to limit ICE's power to apprehend, charge, detain, administratively prosecute, or remove any alien unlawfully in the United States." In other words, Moore can throw out anyone he wants.
因此，尽管12月12日的备忘录指出只有真正的罪犯，而不是交通违法者，才应该被拘留，但在随后的一页中，它引用说：“本指南中的任何内容都不应被解释为限制ICE逮捕、指控、拘留、行政起诉或驱逐任何非法居留在美国的外国人的权力。”换句话说，摩尔可以驱逐他想驱逐的任何人。
So Broward was full of hundreds of people needing to make their case to ICE. After about a week, the activists had taken on dozens of detainees, were holding press conferences, counseling families. Mo says at the peak, they were working from 7:00 AM until 11:00 PM, sometimes later.
所以布劳沃德挤满了数百名需要向ICE陈情的人。大约一周后，活动家们接手了几十个被拘留者的案子，举行了新闻发布会，为家属提供咨询。Mo说在高峰期，他们从早上7点一直工作到晚上11点，有时更晚。
During the infiltration, Mo and the other activists scrambled to keep up with this huge demand Claudio and Marco and Viri were finding inside.
在渗透期间，Mo和其他活动家竭尽全力应对克劳迪奥、马可和Viri在里面发现的巨大需求。
So tell him to try and refuse to board, like do that same strategy as Andy that he did, which was he told the pilot that he was afraid that his life is in danger. He refused to board.
告诉他尝试拒绝登机，做和安迪一样的策略，他告诉飞行员他的生命受到威胁。他拒绝登机。
There's a video of Mo on a typical day during the infiltration. You can see him pacing the halls of the house they're working out of. He's on the phone with Marco trying to feed advice to a detainee at Broward, a guy who's scheduled to be deported on an airplane that afternoon.
有一个关于Mo在渗透期间典型一天的视频。你可以看到他在工作的房子的走廊里踱步。他在和马可通电话，试图给布劳沃德的一名被拘留者提供建议，那个家伙定于当天下午乘飞机被驱逐出境。
Tell him to refuse to put on his seat belt and those sorts of things. I mean, ICE can drug him right there on the spot if they want to. So just try and see if he can stall it and say his life is in danger. I don't know how else people stall that [BLEEP]. But can you please, please, please try and find out what time his flight is?
告诉他拒绝系安全带之类的东西。我的意思是，ICE如果想的话，可以当场给他注射药物。所以试着看他能不能拖延一下，并说他的生命受到了威胁。我不知道还有什么办法可以拖延这件[消音]事。但请你务必一定要想办法查出他的航班是几点？
Then after Marco had been in Broward for just over three weeks, the group decided it was time to make their next move.
在马可进入布劳沃德仅仅三周多后，小组决定采取下一步行动。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
What they did next was make the infiltration public. Marco and Viri both did interviews over detention center phones with TV stations outside.
他们接下来做的是让渗透行动公开化。马可和Viri都通过拘留中心的电话接受了外面电视台的采访。
So Marco spoke with Univision, and I spoke with Telemundo. It was, like, a Thursday evening. This is Broward with all these Hispanic detainees. So that's on, like, every TV.
马可接受了Univision的采访，我接受了Telemundo的采访。那是一个星期四的晚上。布劳沃德有那么多西班牙裔被拘留者。所以电视上都在播。
So Marco and I are on there, and everybody's like, [SPANISH]. They're like, the infiltrator. She's here. And people were coming into the room.
马可和我都出现在电视上，每个人都说，（西班牙语）。他们说，那个渗透者。她在这儿。人们开始走进房间。
You probably can already imagine what happened next. They got kicked out.
你大概已经能想到接下来发生了什么。他们被踢了出来。
That happened on Thursday evening. Friday morning, ICE calls us to an office and, like, Simone Lee-Fatt is her name. And she said, I'm here because you all meet the requirements for release. And I was like, OK, why aren't you bringing everybody else that meets the requirements for release as well?
那是周四晚上发生的事。周五早上，ICE把我们叫到一个办公室，那个叫西蒙娜·李法特（Simone Lee-Fatt）。她说，我来这里是因为你们都符合释放要求。我当时说，好的，为什么你不把其他所有符合释放要求的人也带出来呢？
I'm not in the business of telling you about anybody else's case. So please, like, you meet the requirements for release. All of a sudden, right? Like, what a coincidence that after this interview and people make a big deal, we meet the requirements for release. It took two weeks. Wow.
我不负责告诉你任何其他人的案子。所以请，你们符合释放要求。突然间，对吧？真是巧合，在这次采访和人们大做文章之后，我们符合释放要求了。花了两个星期。哇。
In a sense, this was true. The activists say that some days, the main requirement to get released seemed to be that you get media attention. Now Marco and Viri had done just that. About an hour later, they were being released.
从某种意义上说，这是真的。活动家们说，有时，获得释放的主要条件似乎是你获得了媒体关注。现在马可和Viri正是这样做的。大约一小时后，他们被释放了。
To give you a sense of what the whole thing meant to those held at Broward, it's worth mentioning what happened. After Marco and Viri were kicked out, detainees demanded to know what happened to them. Right away, people gathered in the courtyard in the middle of the detention center and refused to move, yelling and chanting. Only when Claudio was assured that they had been set free did everyone agree to go back to their rooms.
为了让你了解这一切对布劳沃德被关押的人意味着什么，值得一提的是发生了什么。马可和Viri被赶走后，被拘留者要求知道他们发生了什么事。人们立即聚集在拘留中心中间的庭院里并拒绝移动，大声叫喊和呼喊。直到确认他们被释放后，每个人才同意回到房间。
That weekend, the detainees held a hunger strike to protest their incarceration. Claudio Rojas was still inside for a month after Marco and Viri were released. He says the change was remarkable. He says he saw new ICE staff brought in to review people's cases, and people started getting out.
那个周末，被拘留者举行了绝食抗议以抗议监禁。在马可和Viri被释放后，克劳迪奥·罗哈斯还在里面待了一个月。他说变化是显而易见的。他说他看到有新的ICE工作人员被调来审查人们的案子，人们开始获释。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
When you leave the lunchroom and go into the store where they sell goods, that's where they've put up the court forms. It's like a form for the court.
当你离开食堂去商店买东西时，那就是他们张贴法院表格的地方。就像法庭表格一样。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Of the people who had court that day.
那天有法庭活动的人的名单。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Before, the 25 people who may have had court that day, maybe one or two would qualify for bond.
以前，那天可能有25个人上法庭，也许一两个人有资格获得保释。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Everybody else would be deported. After Mohammad's people started working, and the system opened, we saw the change, when that closed system opened up.
其他人都会被驱逐。在穆罕默德的人开始工作后，系统开放了，我们看到了变化，那个封闭的系统开放了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
When the system opened up, those pieces of paper and now said next to each name, relief, relief, relief, bond, bond, bond.
当系统开放时，那些纸条现在在每个名字旁边写着，救济，救济，救济，保释，保释，保释。
That's what Claudio says he saw. But the total effects of the infiltration, well, they're actually kind of hard to pin down. The activists say they took on around 150 cases and got somewhere between 40 and 60 people out of Broward. ICE denies that the activists got anyone out. They say those people would have been released anyway.
这就是克劳迪奥所说的他所看到的。但渗透行动的总体效果，嗯，实际上很难确定。活动家们说他们接手了大约150个案子，并设法让40到60人离开了布劳沃德。ICE否认活动家帮任何人出了狱。他们说这些人本来就会被释放。
Claudio was released about a month after Marco and Viri. He'd spent a total of seven months in detention. One day, an ICE agent just took him to an office, told him he'd met the qualifications for release.
克劳迪奥在马可和Viri离开一个月后被释放。他在拘留所总共待了七个月。一天，一名ICE代理人只是带他去了一个办公室，告诉他他符合释放资格。
Did they tell you why they let you out?
他们有没有告诉你为什么让你出来？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
No.
没有。
In the months after the infiltration, 26 members of Congress signed a letter to ICE head John Morton. It was put together by Congressman Ted Deutsch, whose district includes Broward. And it asked for a case-by-case review of every single person in the facility.
在渗透后的几个月里，26名国会议员签署了一封给ICE负责人约翰·莫顿的信。这封信由国会议员泰德·德奇（Ted Deutsch）组织，他的选区包括布劳沃德。信中要求对设施内的每一个人进行逐案审查。
When I talked to Congressman Deutsch more than half a year after ICE received his group's letter, he said ICE had refused to do what the letter asked for. He says low priority people are still being locked up across the country, which he thinks is a problem.
当我在ICE收到他小组的信半年多后采访德奇议员时，他说ICE拒绝做信中所要求的事。他说低优先级的人仍然在全国各地被关押，他认为这是一个问题。
The immigration reform bill that's now in the Senate tries to address this head on. It orders ICE not to detain any low priority immigrants unless there's a specific reason, like they're a flight risk.
目前在参议院的移民改革法案试图正面解决这个问题。它命令ICE除非有特定原因，如逃跑风险，否则不得拘留任何低优先级移民。
But what are you noticing, Cynthia, in your surroundings? Like all of this is happening--
但你注意到了什么，辛西娅，在你的环境中？就像这一切正在发生——
Like how many people are there and who's talking to who.
比如有多少人在那里，谁在和谁说话。
And while you're doing that, they're going to cuff your hands like this instead of cuffing you like this.
当你这样做的时候，他们会这样给你上手铐，而不是这样。
In April, Mo and Viri and three other organizers were in a condo in the outskirts of Raleigh, North Carolina. Mo and several of the organizers had just finished driving in from Texas to be there. The point of this meeting was to train two young activists to be the new infiltrators to sneak into another detention center in Michigan.
四月份，Mo、Viri和其他三名组织者在北卡罗来纳州罗利郊外的一间公寓里。Mo和几名组织者刚从得克萨斯州开车过来。这次会议的目的是训练两名年轻的活动家成为新的渗透者，潜入密歇根州的另一个拘留中心。
The meeting was surreal. The condo belonged to the family of one of the women planning to go in, though her parents had no idea she was planning to do this. They weren't home. Her brother played video games with a friend while just outside the door, the activists sat around the kitchen table, discussing what the women should expect when ICE brings them into custody.
会议是超现实的。这间公寓属于其中一名计划进入的女性的家人，虽然她父母根本不知道她打算做这种事。他们不在家。她的弟弟在和朋友玩视频游戏，而就在门外，活动家们坐在餐桌旁，讨论当ICE将她们拘留时，她们应该期待什么。
They're going to ask you about your family, at which point you can choose to answer or not, right? About your family?
他们会问你关于你家人的问题，这时你可以选择回答或不回答，对吗？关于你的家人？
Yeah, you can choose to answer or not, but I mean, obviously, don't say anything. And so that's the part I was talking to you about yesterday. Did you answer--
是的，你可以选择回答或不回答，但我的意思是，显然，什么都不要说。这就是我昨天和你谈的那部分。你回答了——
Maybe the most striking thing about seeing all this, though is how different it was from the early videos of the activists preparing for Broward. Those videos exist. I've seen them. And in those, it's clear that nobody has too much of an idea about what they're doing. It feels like 20-year-olds imagining something they've been taught never to do but otherwise know very little about, with cartoonish ideas about how the cops will treat them.
然而，看到这一切最引人注目的一点是，它与活动家们为布劳沃德做准备的早期视频有何不同。那些视频确实存在。我看过。在那些视频里，很明显没有人太清楚自己在做什么。感觉就像20岁的人在想象一件他们被教导永远不要做，但除此之外知之甚少的事情，对警察如何对待他们有着卡通式的想法。
This night in Raleigh, Viri and Mo tell anecdotes about Florida, strategies for gaining people's trust, how not to attract attention. The two women ask questions, and Mo and Viri explain what to expect in detention. Their advice is matter of fact and practical.
在罗利的这个夜晚，Viri和Mo讲述了关于佛罗里达的轶事、赢得人们信任的策略、如何不吸引注意。那两名女性提出问题，Mo和Viri解释了在拘留中会发生什么。他们的建议是务实的、实用的。
They found a strategy that works, that frees people. And this summer, they're rolling it out in seven detention centers across the country. Michigan's just one of them. They're not waiting for lawmakers to fix the problem from Washington. When all this started, infiltration felt outlandish and risky. Now, it just seems pragmatic.
他们找到了一种有效的、能释放人的策略。今年夏天，他们将在全国七个拘留中心推广。密歇根只是其中之一。他们不再等待华盛顿的立法者解决这个问题。这一切开始时，渗透感觉既古怪又有风险。现在，这似乎只是务实之举。
Michael May. He also wrote a version of this story for American Prospect Magazine . Thanks to filmmaker Alex Rivera, who's working on a movie about this and provided audio of the activists when they got detained.
迈克尔·梅。他还为《美国展望》杂志撰写了这个故事的一个版本。感谢电影制作人亚历克斯·里维拉（Alex Rivera），他正在拍摄一部关于此事的电影，并提供了活动家被拘留时的音频。
Coming up, disobeying a rule that is so important in your family that you wait half your lifetime before admitting it to your parents. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，违背家庭中一条如此重要的规则，以至于你等了半辈子才向父母承认。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续中揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "The One Thing You're Not Supposed To Do." We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, The Gun Thing You're Not Supposed To Do.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，“你本不该做的一件事”。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，枪支本不该做的事。
Christine Gentry grew up in a house in Texas. And there was one rule in their house that their dad would tell her and her two brothers now and then all through their childhoods, to be sure they would never disobey this rule. And everybody in the family thought she never had disobeyed this rule until this past Christmas.
克里斯汀·金特里（Christine Gentry）在德克萨斯州的一个家里长大。他们家里有一条规则，她父亲在她们童年时期时常告诉她和她的两个兄弟，以确保他们永远不会违背这条规则。家里每个人都以为她从来没有违背过这条规则，直到去年圣诞节。
This past Christmas, she went home to see her family from New York City, where she lives now. And one night, she was with her family. They went out to a sports bar for dinner. Here's Christine's mom, Jan.
去年圣诞节，她从现在居住的纽约市回到了家看望家人。一天晚上，她和家人在一起。他们出去一家体育酒吧吃晚饭。这是克里斯汀的妈妈，简（Jan）。
Well, we were all sitting around at Buffalo Wild Wings, Matt, our son who'd just gotten out of the Marines, his wife, and Ron and I. And we were just enjoying our company.
嗯，我们都坐在布法罗狂野烧烤店（Buffalo Wild Wings），刚从海军陆战队退伍的儿子马特（Matt）、他的妻子，还有罗恩（Ron）和我。我们正享受在一起的时光。
Ron, by the way, is Christine's dad. Anyway, here's Christine.
顺便说一下，罗恩是克里斯汀的父亲。总之，这是克里斯汀。
And because it was a sports bar, there were these screens everywhere. And because Sandy Hook had just happened, almost every screen in the place had some kind of news program running about it.
因为那是体育酒吧，到处都是屏幕。而且因为桑迪胡克小学枪击案刚刚发生，店里几乎每个屏幕上都在播放关于它的新闻节目。
That's how the subject came up.
这就是话题引发的原因。
I remember us sitting at the bar, and we were arguing about Sandy Hook.
我记得我们坐在吧台，我们正在争论桑迪胡克。
That's Christine's brother, Matt.
那是克里斯汀的哥哥马特。
I think the beers hadn't even arrived. They start talking. I was like, oh boy, here we go. Like, I know that this is going to be used-- now they are going to come for our guns. Like, that's what's going to happen.
我想啤酒还没端上来。他们开始谈论。我当时想，哦天哪，开始了。就像，我知道这会被利用——现在他们要来收我们的枪了。就像，这就是要发生的事。
I mean, we definitely feel that that sparked a movement for the government to come after the guns and not necessarily come into our homes and take them, but they were already starting to pass gun bills and gun right laws.
我的意思是，我们绝对觉得这引发了一场政府来针对枪支的运动，不一定是进屋收走它们，但他们已经开始通过枪支法案和枪支权利法了。
And my dad and my brother are both wearing these brand new NRA hats that they had gone out to buy right after Sandy Hook.
我父亲和我哥哥都戴着这些他们在桑迪胡克后刚买的全新的NRA（美国步枪协会）帽子。
Sandy Hook happened, and they thought, we have to stand up for what we believe in. They got new NRA hats?
桑迪胡克发生了，他们想，我们必须坚持我们的信念。他们买了新的NRA帽子？
Yes.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
I don't believe that that's the case. I believe we had already joined the NRA, then seven weeks later, they sent us the caps.
我不认为事实是这样。我相信我们已经加入了NRA，七周后，他们给我们寄来了帽子。
They came in the mail.
它们是邮寄来的。
Christine's dad and mom say, no, she is mistaken about the hats.
克里斯汀的父亲和母亲说，不，关于帽子她弄错了。
No, no, no.
不，不，不。
Oh, that's funny. No, actually, they just came in the mail.
哦，真有趣。不，实际上，它们只是邮寄来的。
They just came in the mail. They had nothing to do with that.
它们只是邮寄来的。这和那件事完全没关系。
So Christine's the one blue stater in the family, and she says that she generally tries to keep her beliefs to herself during these kinds of conversations. But then the discussion took a turn.
所以克里斯汀是家里唯一的民主党支持者，她说在这种谈话中，她通常尽量把自己的观点藏在心里。但后来讨论发生了转变。
My dad started blaming Adam Lanza's mother.
我父亲开始责怪亚当·兰扎（Adam Lanza）的母亲。
The shooter's mother.
枪手的母亲。
Yes.
是的。
And I said, well, I think that the mother is as much at fault as the boy that shot the kids. And she kind of looked surprised when I said that. And Matthew said, yeah, you know, we were taught from an early age not to handle guns and not to do things like that.
我说，嗯，我觉得母亲和射杀孩子的男孩一样有过错。当我这么说时，她看起来有点惊讶。马修说，是啊，你知道，我们从小就被教导不要碰枪，不要做那种事。
And this finally brings us to the biggest rule of their house when they were growing up. Ron collected antique guns. He hunted. He taught the kids to shoot and hunt from an early age. And so there were always lots of guns around the house, maybe 25, 30 guns.
这最终带出了他们成长过程中家里最大的一条规则。罗恩收藏古董枪。他打猎。他从小就教孩子们射击和打猎。所以家里总是有很多枪，大概25、30把枪。
One of my earliest memories is actually my dad taking a pistol apart and cleaning it and putting it back together. And he called me over to watch him do it. He said, listen, I want to tell you something about guns. I don't want you to be afraid of them, but I want you to respect them. And if you ever have any questions, if you ever want to touch one, if you ever want to shoot one, just ask me. But you are never to touch a gun when I'm not at home, when I'm not here.
我最早的记忆之一实际上是我父亲拆解一把手枪，清洗它并重新组装。他叫我过去看他这样做。他说，听着，我想告诉你一些关于枪的事。我不希望你害怕它们，但我希望你尊重它们。如果你有任何问题，如果你想碰一把，如果你想射击一把，尽管问我。但当我不在家，我不在的时候，你永远不要碰枪。
OK, so that was the rule.
好了，这就是规则。
Oh, absolutely. They could never touch a gun unless I was there. And they could never touch a gun unless I physically got it first and made sure that the gun was clear.
哦，当然。除非我在那里，否则她们永远不能碰枪。除非我先亲自检查并确保枪是空的，否则她们永远不能碰枪。
You know, that's what he preached when we were kids to everybody. Like, all you've got to do is teach your kids how to use them and what to do with them, and everything will be OK. He preaches that to everybody that ever has any questions about firearms and their children.
你知道，这就是他教导我们孩子时传授的东西。就像，你所要做的就是教你的孩子如何使用它们以及该做什么，一切都会好起来的。对于任何对枪支和孩子有疑问的人，他都会这样说。
So Christine says that she was finding this whole conversation at the bar pretty upsetting. She was a high school teacher for five years. She still teaches classes in the public schools. And she had a very different reaction to Sandy Hook than her dad's and her brother's reactions.
所以克里斯汀说，她觉得酒吧里的整个谈话非常令人不安。她当过五年高中老师。她仍然在公立学校教书。她对桑迪胡克的反应与她父亲和哥哥的反应截然不同。
And she remembers saying to her dad, OK, so you think that you did everything right as a parent teaching us about guns. And he said, yeah, I taught you right. And Matt chimed in agreeing with her dad.
她记得对父亲说，好吧，所以你认为你作为父母在教我们枪支方面做的一切都是正确的。他说，是的，我教得对。马特也表示同意她父亲的观点。
What Matt said was, it was so good that Dad taught us all that and that he taught us never to touch the guns, and we never did. And at that point, Christine got very emotional and actually kind of tearfully broke down and said, that's not true.
马特说的是，爸爸教我们这一切，教我们永远不要碰枪真是太好了，我们从来没碰过。就在那时，克里斯汀情绪非常激动，实际上含着泪水崩溃了说，那不是真的。
And then that's when she went into her story about what had happened.
然后她就开始讲述她发生的事情。
Here's the story. Back in her junior year of high school, Christine was in this play where her character in the play committed suicide. One day, her parents were out at one of Matt's soccer games, and Christine was home babysitting with her little brother, Derek, who was around eight at the time. And Christine was in her room rehearsing this scene where she's supposed to shoot herself.
故事是这样的。在高中三年级时，克里斯汀参加了这部戏剧，她在剧中的角色自杀了。一天，她父母去参加马特的一场足球比赛，克里斯汀在家照顾当时大约八岁的小弟弟德里克（Derek）。克里斯汀在房间里排练这一幕，她本该开枪打死自己。
When I had this thought. I was like, man, this would be so much more intense if I was rehearsing with a real gun. And I know where to get one. I walked into my parents room, I shut the door, I sat on their bed, and I opened my mom's underwear drawer where I knew my dad kept the gun-- that I'd shot multiple times.
当时我有了这个想法。我心想，伙计，如果我用真枪排练会更强烈得多。而且我知道去哪里能弄到一把。我走进父母的房间，关上门，坐在他们的床上，拉开了我妈妈的内衣抽屉，我知道爸爸把枪放在那里——我射击过很多次的那把枪。
And the pistol that we keep in our bedroom was a semi-automatic with a clip.
而我们放在卧室里的那把手枪是一把带弹夹的半自动手枪。
I took the clip out, and I started rehearsing.
我取出了弹夹，开始排练。
OK, so you took the clip out.
好了，所以你取出了弹夹。
Forgetting, of course, about the bullet in the chamber.
当然忘记了枪膛里还有一颗子弹。
Because there's still one bullet in the chamber if you take the clip out.
因为如果你取出弹夹，枪膛里还是有一颗子弹。
Exactly.
正是如此。
She pointed the gun at her head, was about to pull the trigger, and then this thought popped into the back of her mind.
她把枪指着自己的头，正要扣动扳机，然后这个想法闪过她的脑海。
She thought for a second, I'd better check it just to make sure that it's not loaded. And she pointed it at the floor and squeezed the trigger, and it went off.
她想了一秒钟，最好检查一下，确保它没有上膛。她把它指着地板扣动了扳机，枪响了。
It was an absolutely terrifying moment, probably my biggest secret. I never told anybody. And I didn't shoot a gun after. I didn't want to touch one again, and I haven't.
那是一个极其恐怖的时刻，可能是我最大的秘密。我从没告诉过任何人。在那之后我再没射击过枪。我不想再碰一把，而且我从来没碰过。
Her little brother, hearing the blast, ran into the bedroom, and she told him that it was just a car backfiring outside. He left, and she poked around the floor until she found the bullet hole.
她的小弟弟听到爆炸声跑进卧室，她告诉他那只是外面的汽车回火。他离开了，她在地板上摸索直到发现了弹孔。
We didn't have a finished basement. It was just mud beneath our house. And it had gone through into that mud. And my parents had this really old shag carpet that I was able to tease enough with my fingernails to cover up the hole.
我们没有完成的地下室。房子下面只有泥土。子弹穿过打进了泥土里。而我父母有那种非常旧的长毛地毯，我能够用指甲拨弄足够的绒毛遮住那个洞。
And so she's telling us this story.
所以她正在告诉我们这个故事。
And I remember my dad being very upset. He actually-- I think he cried.
我记得我父亲非常难过。他实际上……我想他哭了。
We all did.
我们都哭了。
Yeah. Yeah, we all did.
是的。是的，我们都哭了。
And what were you feeling at that moment? When she first told you, Ron, what did you feel?
当你第一次听到时，你那时候在想什么，罗恩，你感觉到了什么？
At first, disbelief. Christine couldn't have done that. Not Christie. No, she would have never done that.
起初，难以置信。克里斯汀不可能做那种事。不是克里斯汀。不，她永远不会做那种事。
But then I realized that, yes, it happened. And then what if it really would have killed her? She'd have been laying there when we came home. We'd have never known what happened.
但后来我意识到，是的，它发生了。如果它真的把她打死了呢？当我们回家时，她会躺在那里。我们永远不会知道发生了什么。
My daughter was dead. She blew her brains out. Why did she do that? What did we do? What's going on? Whether she committed suicide, whether it was an accident, I mean, how would you know?
我女儿死了。她把自己的脑浆打出来了。她为什么要那样做？我们做了什么？发生了什么？无论是她自杀还是事故，我的意思是，你怎么会知道？
That is the craziest thing that if the gun had gone off, you would have just thought, like, she killed herself? But why? And then, you know, I can imagine a family after that thinking, well, do you think she was rehearsing for her play? And then everybody would go, no, that's ridiculous.
这是最疯狂的事情，如果枪真的响了，你只会想，她自杀了？但为什么？然后，你知道，我可以想象一个家庭在那之后想，好吧，你觉得她在为她的戏排练吗？然后每个人都会说，不，这太荒谬了。
No, because that wouldn't have been Christine. She's always very obedient. And I'm very thankful that she shared it with us.
不，因为那不会是克里斯汀。她总是非常听话。我很感激她与我们分享了这一点。
And so did she convince you?
所以你被说服了吗？
Of what?
关于什么？
That you can do everything right and still--
你即使做了一切正确的事，仍然——
Oh, absolutely. Absolutely. I taught them the right way to do it. At 17 years old, you think, it's sunk in. It's done. And you find out that you're wrong.
哦，绝对。绝对。我教她们正确的方法去做。在17岁时，你认为，它已经深入人心了。它完成了。结果发现你是错的。
Wait, so you're saying that if she had actually succeeded in shooting herself, you would have blamed yourself.
等等，所以你的意思是，如果她真的成功自杀了，你会责怪自己。
Absolutely. How could you not? How could you not? It's a second from going either direction. One second. It could have been either way. One second's all it was.
绝对。你怎么能不呢？你怎么能不呢？这离走向任何一个方向只有一秒钟之差。一秒钟。它可能是任何一个方向。只有一秒钟而已。
What do you think would have happened if she would have told you when she was 16 that she had done this?
如果你16岁时她告诉你她做了这件事，你觉得会发生什么？
Well, personally, I think a lot of things would have changed. I would have probably-- at that particular time, I probably would have bought a safe, a small hand safe with-- you put your fingerprints on it, you can get it open, to where somebody couldn't have got a hold of it.
嗯，就个人而言，我想很多事情会改变。我可能会——在那个特定的时间，我可能会买一个保险箱，一个小手持保险箱，带有——你把指纹放上去，就能打开，这样别人就拿不到了。
Gotten a hold of the gun, you mean.
你是说拿不到枪。
Correct. And I would think that maybe I would have been a little bit more thoughtful about what I told other people.
正确。我想也许我会对我告诉别人的话更加谨慎一些。
He means the advice that he was always giving people about kids and guns. A couple months after this Christmas conversation, Jan and Ron took all the handguns out of their house, they were so upset about it. Now those guns are back, but when friends' children come over to the house, the guns are locked away.
他的意思是，他总是给人们关于孩子和枪的建议。在这个圣诞节谈话几个月后，简和罗恩把家里所有的手枪都拿走了，他们对此感到非常难过。现在那些枪又回来了，但当朋友的孩子来家里时，枪都被锁了起来。
Ron's not getting rid of his guns. His views of gun ownership and gun rights have not changed. He still thinks the media does not give enough coverage to the millions of gun owners who safely own their weapons and have great experiences hunting and shooting with their kids and do not do crazy stuff with their guns. He's probably right about that. The only thing that's changed is that he thinks he should have locked up his weapons when he wasn't at home.
罗恩并没有放弃他的枪。他对枪支所有权和枪支权利的看法没有改变。他仍然认为媒体没有给予那些安全拥有武器、和孩子打猎和射击有很好体验、且不会拿枪做疯狂事的数百万枪支所有者足够的报道。关于这一点，他可能是对的。唯一改变的是，他认为他不该在家时应该锁好武器。
Christine still feels a little embarrassed that she dropped this story that was so upsetting for her parents onto them to win an argument about Sandy Hook. And as for her brother Matt, well, his reaction that night was very different from his parents'.
克里斯汀仍然觉得有点尴尬，她把这个让父母如此不安的故事抛给他们，只是为了在关于桑迪胡克的争论中获胜。至于她的兄弟马特，嗯，那晚他的反应与父母截然不同。
I just kept calling her how stupid she was and, like, she must have been adopted. And my sister asked me if it changed anything the way I would do, or when I have kids, would I do exactly what Dad did, or would I change it? And I told her, no. I wouldn't change anything.
我只是不断地叫她有多愚蠢，就像，她一定是领养的。我妹妹问我，这是否改变了我做事的任何方式，或者当我有了孩子，我会做和爸爸完全一样的事，还是会改变？我告诉她，不。我什么都不会改变。
So your plan is when you have kids, they're not going to be idiots like your sister.
所以你的计划是当你有了孩子，他们不会像你妹妹那样是白痴。
Right.
正确。
You know I'm making a joke here, right?
你知道我在开玩笑，对吧？
Yeah. Well if they are, I'll lock them in the closet, give them a food bowl or something.
是的。如果他们是，我就把他们锁在壁橱里，给他们一个食盆什么的。
[MUSIC - "DON'T DO IT" BY RUSTY YORK AND WILLARD HALE]
（音乐 - 鲁斯蒂·约克和威拉德·黑尔演唱的《别做那件事》）
Act Three, Out of the Woods. OK, this last story is about a moose-- that's right, a moose-- who does not just do the one thing that you probably shouldn't do as a moose, he does, like, a series of them. This story comes from Ben Loory.
第三幕，走出森林。好的，这最后一个故事是关于一只麋鹿——没错，一只麋鹿——它不仅做了一件你可能作为麋鹿不该做的事，它做了，比如，一系列这样的事。这个故事来自本·卢里（Ben Loory）。
A moose is standing in the forest when he suddenly hears a noise. He looks up and sees a plane flying overhead. As he watches, a man jumps out. A parachute bursts open, and the man floats safely down.
一只麋鹿站在森林里，突然听到一阵噪音。它抬头看到一架飞机在头顶飞过。当它看着时，一个男人跳了出来。降落伞爆开，男人安全地飘落下来。
The moose goes over and looks at him. "Hello," says the man, gathering in his parachute. "Hello," says the moose. "What are you doing?" "Oh, nothing," says the man, "nothing much. I just jump out of planes every now and then."
麋鹿走过去看着他。“你好，”男人一边收降落伞一边说。“你好，”麋鹿说。“你在做什么？”“噢，没什么，”男人说，“没什么大不了的。我只是偶尔从飞机上跳下来。”
The moose looks up at the sky. "Is it fun?" he says. "Oh, yes," says the man. "Have you never done it?" "Me?" says the moose. "Oh, no." "Well, come along with me," says the man. "We'll go back to town and get you all suited up, and then off we'll go. What do you say?"
麋鹿抬头看向天空。“很有趣吗？”它说。“噢，是的，”男人说。“你从来没做过吗？”“我？”麋鹿说。“噢，不。”“好吧，跟我一起来，”男人说。“我们回镇上把你打扮好，然后我们就走。你觉得怎么样？”
"I don't know," says the moose. "Isn't it dangerous?" "Dangerous?" says the man. "No, not at all. Well, a little, but hey, isn't everything?" "I guess," says the moose, "when you put it that way."
“我不知道，”麋鹿说。“这危险吗？”“危险？”男人说。“不，一点也不。嗯，有一点，但嘿，什么事不是呢？”“我想是吧，”麋鹿说，“当你这么说的时候。”
And after a while, he starts to nod. "All right," he says, "OK." "Great," says the man. "You're going to love it." And he claps the moose on the back, and the two of them start off.
过了一会儿，它开始点头。“好吧，”它说，“好的。”“太棒了，”男人说。“你会喜欢它的。”他拍了拍麋鹿的后背，两人开始了出发。
When they get to the edge of the city, the moose suddenly stops. "What about the people?" he says. "What about them?" says the man. "Well," says the moose, "I'm not saying that I'm afraid of them, understand. But they're always out in the woods looking at me. It makes me nervous. I don't know what they want."
当他们到达城市边缘时，麋鹿突然停了下来。“那人们呢？”它说。“他们怎么了？”男人说。“嗯，”麋鹿说，“我不是说我怕他们，你要明白。但他们总是在树林里盯着我看。这让我很紧张。我不知道他们想要什么。”
"Hm," says the man. "I doubt they want anything. But OK, here's what we'll do." He takes an extra t-shirt and hat out of his bag. "Put these on. Nobody will recognize you," he says. The moose looks at the offered disguise for a moment. "All right," he says, and puts it on.
“嗯，”男人说。“我怀疑他们想要什么。但好吧，我们这样做。”他从包里拿出一件额外的T恤和帽子。“把这些穿上。没人会认出你，”他说。麋鹿看着提供的伪装片刻。“好吧，”它说，穿上了它们。
The man and the moose wander into town. The moose is very, very nervous. "Hey, Tom," someone says, and a group of people come over. "How'd your jump go today, and who's that?"
男人和麋鹿走进了镇上。麋鹿非常非常紧张。“嘿，汤姆，”有人说，一群人走了过来。“你今天的跳伞怎么样，那是谁？”
The man turns and looks at the moose. "This is my friend, Lawrence," he says. "He just came in from the coast." "Quite a grip you've got there, Lawrence," says one of the men. "Are you bringing Lawrence to the party?" says another.
男人转过身看着麋鹿。“这是我的朋友，劳伦斯（Lawrence），”他说。“他刚从海岸过来。”“你真有劲，劳伦斯，”其中一个人说。“你要带劳伦斯去派对吗？”另一个人说。
"Shoot," says the man, looking at the moose. "I completely forgot about that. You mind coming along to this thing tonight? It's sort of a shindig for my most recent jump." "Sure," says the moose, feeling self-conscious, "Sure. That'll be fine."
“该死，”男人看着麋鹿说。“我完全忘了那件事。你介意今晚参加这个吗？这算是为我最近一次跳伞举办的小型聚会。”“当然，”麋鹿感到不自然地说，“当然。那没问题。”
That night the man and the moose go to the party. It is at the Explorers Club. There are a number of long tables arranged in a square. The man and the moose are in the place of honor.
那天晚上男人和麋鹿去了派对。在探险家俱乐部。有几张长桌排成一个正方形。男人和麋鹿在荣誉席上。
The moose is having a wonderful time. The food is really very good. Different people make different speeches, and the moose finds the waitress quite fascinating.
麋鹿玩得很开心。食物真的很好。不同的人发表了不同的演讲，麋鹿觉得女服务员很迷人。
But then, suddenly, something draws his attention-- heads, animal heads. They're lining the walls all around the top-- lion, zebra, deer, elk, and moose. Fear grips the moose's heart. "Killers," he thinks, looking around the room.
但突然，有什么东西吸引了它的注意力——头，动物的头。它们沿着墙壁顶部排列——狮子、斑马、鹿、麋鹿和驯鹿。恐惧抓住了麋鹿的心。“杀手，”它心想，环顾房间。
"What is it?" says the man, sensing trouble. The moose turns and looks at him in horror. "You're trying to kill me," he says, his voice a whisper. "You brought me here to kill me." "What?" says the man. "Why would I do that? I don't understand."
“怎么了？”男人说，感觉到麻烦。麋鹿转头看着他，满脸恐惧。“你想杀了我，”它说，声音轻得像耳语。“你带我到这里来杀我。”“什么？”男人说。“我为什么要那样做？我不明白。”
But the moose is too scared to explain. He stumbles backward to his feet. He points a hoof at the abomination on the wall.
但麋鹿太害怕了，无法解释。它踉跄着后退站稳。它伸出蹄子指着墙上的那个可憎之物。
The man sees it, then his eyes go wide. "My god," he says, "I just didn't think." He reaches out to reassure the moose, but his hand grabs the t-shirt, and it rips and falls off. And then, to make matters worse, the moose's hat tumbles to the floor.
男人看到了它，然后眼睛瞪大了。“天哪，”他说，“我就是没想到。”他伸出手安抚麋鹿，但他的手抓住了T恤，它撕破并掉了下来。然后，更糟糕的是，麋鹿的帽子掉到了地板上。
Everybody turns. "A moose," they cry. "Get him. Get him. Get the guns." The moose takes off. He galumphs out of the ballroom, knocking people over left and right. He barrels through the doors and off down the hall. The members of the Explorers Club are striking the glass on the gun cases. "Hurry," they are yelling, "It's a big one, the biggest."
每个人都转过身。“一只麋鹿，”他们大喊。“抓住他。抓住他。去拿枪。”麋鹿跑开了。它笨拙地跳出宴会厅，左冲右撞地把人撞倒。它撞开门，冲进走廊。探险家俱乐部的成员正在敲碎枪柜上的玻璃。“快，”他们大喊，“这是一个大家伙，最大的。”
The moose careens out into the street. He's weaving in and out of cars. There's honking and screaming. The moose has never been so terrified.
麋鹿狂奔到街上。它在汽车之间穿梭。到处是喇叭声和尖叫声。麋鹿从未如此害怕。
"Wait, wait," cries a voice. The moose looks back. It's the man running after him. "I'm sorry," yells the man. "I didn't think. I'm so stupid. I'll make it up to you. I'll get you out of this, I swear."
“等等，等等，”一个声音叫道。麋鹿回头看。那是男人在后面追。“我很抱歉，”男人大喊。“我没想到。我太蠢了。我会补偿你的。我会带你走出这个境地，我发誓。”
"Are you kidding?" yells the moose. "Why should I trust you?" Just then, gunfire erupts. It's the Explorers Club hot on their trail. Bullets whiz past, close, closer. "I can take you to the plane," says the man. "It's your only chance."
“你在开玩笑吗？”麋鹿大喊。“我为什么要信任你？”就在这时，枪声爆发了。那是探险家俱乐部在紧追不舍。子弹呼啸而过，很近，更近了。“我可以带你去飞机，”男人说。“这是你唯一的机会。”
The moose thinks. Another bullet whizzes by. "All right," the moose yells. "Climb on." The man jumps on, and the two of them charge through the streets. "Turn left," yells the man, and the moose turns. Up ahead is the airfield, behind, the men with guns, getting closer with every passing second.
麋鹿思考着。另一颗子弹呼啸而过。“好吧，”麋鹿大喊。“爬上来。”男人跳上去，两人穿过街道。“向左转，”男人大喊，麋鹿转弯了。前方就是机场，身后，拿枪的人，每一秒钟都在接近。
"There's the plane," the man hollers, and the two dive on board. The man guns it, and the plane taxis toward the runway. Behind them, the Explorers Club lines up in a row. "Fire," says the leader. "Fire more."
“那是飞机，”男人大叫，两人跳了上去。男人踩油门，飞机向跑道滑行。在他们身后，探险家俱乐部排成一行。“开火，”领导者说。“继续开火。”
The plane is hit in 10,000 places, but still, it manages to lift off. Behind it trails a cloud of smoke and fire that is terrifying to behold. "We're not going to make it!" the man yells to the moose. "We're going to have to jump." He turns and looks for the parachutes, but there is only one.
飞机在10000个地方被击中，但它仍然设法起飞。身后拖着一团烟火，看起来非常恐怖。“我们要撑不住了！”男人对麋鹿大喊。“我们必须跳机。”他转身寻找降落伞，但只有一个。
"You take it," says the man, pushing it to the moose. But the moose just stares at it in silence. "No, you," says the moose. "I don't even know how to use it. Besides, I wouldn't have gotten this far without you."
“你拿去吧，”男人说，把它塞给麋鹿。但麋鹿只是沉默地盯着它。“不，你拿，”麋鹿说。“我甚至不知道怎么用它。再说，没有你我走不到这一步。”
The man thinks for a moment. "We go together," he finally says. "It might work. It might not. Who knows?"
男人思考片刻。“我们一起，”他最终说。“可能会成功。可能不会。谁知道呢？”
He straps the parachute around them both and edges the moose toward the door. "On the count of three," the man says. And the moose jumps.
他把降落伞绑在两人身上，把麋鹿挪向舱门。“数到三，”男人说。然后麋鹿跳了下去。
The man and the moose plummet through the air. "Is that the forest," the moose calls, "down there?" "Yes," says the man. "Isn't it pretty?" "It is," says the moose. "I can see why you like doing this."
男人和麋鹿在空中坠落。“那是森林吗，”麋鹿问道，“在下面？”“是的，”男人说。“不漂亮吗？”“是啊，”麋鹿说。“我明白你为什么喜欢这么做了。”
At this point, the ground is coming up pretty fast. "All right," says the man, "moment of truth." The two grip the pull cord tightly together. "I hope we can be friends," says the moose.
此时，地面正迅速接近。“好吧，”男人说，“关键时刻到了。”两人紧紧握住拉绳。“希望我们能成为朋友，”麋鹿说。
Ben Loory-- so good, right-- reading a story from his collection of short fiction. It's called Stories for Nighttime and Some for the Day.
本·卢里——太棒了，对吧——读着他短篇小说集中的一个故事。它叫《夜间故事与一些白日故事》（Stories for Nighttime and Some for the Day）。
[MUSIC - "WOKE UP THIS MORNING (THEME FROM THE SOPRANOS)" BY ALABAMA 3]
（音乐 - 阿拉巴马3演唱的《今天早上醒来》（《黑道家族》主题曲））
Our program is produced today by Robyn Semien and myself with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Thea Bennen. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant. Research by Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、美纪·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。西娅·本内（Thea Bennen）提供制作帮助。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）负责研究。达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）和罗伯·格德斯（Rob Geddes）提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
（鸣谢）
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Torey Malatia, who has been doing a lot of flamenco dancing-- that's right, flamenco dancing-- on the sly. He sneaks into these fancy parties. He dances a while, until somebody spots him and declares--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他一直在偷偷地跳弗拉门戈舞——没错，弗拉门戈舞。他溜进那些高级派对。他跳了一会儿，直到有人发现他并宣布——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
They're like, the infiltrator.
他们说，那个渗透者。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多关于美国生活的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "WOKE UP THIS MORNING (THEME FROM THE SOPRANOS)" BY ALABAMA 3]
（音乐 - 阿拉巴马3演唱的《今天早上醒来》（《黑道家族》主题曲））
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。